this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
let's look at the difference between
qualitative and quantitative data
scientists observe and collect different
types of information
called data
so what kind of data can we collect
well
the two main types of data are
qualitative data
and quantitative data
qualitative data includes descriptions
that do not contain numeric values
notice the word qualitative has quality
embedded in it
qualitative data tends to be subjective
impressions such as how tasty one school
lunch is compared to another one
as you can see
qualitative data consists of observable
things that can be described and
recorded in ways other than numerically
now let's talk about quantitative data
unlike qualitative data
quantitative data contains numbers
obtained by counting or measuring
notice the word quantitative has
quantity
embedded in it
for example
recording quantitative data can be as
simple as counting specific things such
as the number of boys in your class
compared to the number of girls
data can also be measurements of length
width
height
volume
as well as mass
or temperature
sometimes scientists will break down
quantitative data into specific types
called discrete data
and continuous data
discrete data can only have a certain
exact value which can't be subdivided
for example if you roll a typical pair
of dice you can roll a 2 or three but
it's impossible to roll a two and a half
you can only roll a whole number between
two and twelve
likewise the number of protons in an
atom is also an example of discrete data
because you can't have half a proton
in contrast continuous data can have
almost any value
for example measurements such as height
come in a range of continuous data
why
because measurements can have any value
in fractions of a unit in this case
meters
in review
qualitative data contains descriptions
that don't use numbers
while quantitative data contains numbers
obtained by counting or measuring both
discrete and continuous data are types
of quantitative data
discrete data can only contain certain
specific values
while continuous data can have almost
any value
[Music]